Finally, New Rule,
there's nothing wrong
with not having
an opinion on something.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Especially if you don't know
what the fuck
you're talking about.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And if you're getting your facts
from TikTok and Instagram
and Facebook,
I don't wanna hear
your hot take
on asymmetrical warfare
because there's a term
for someone
who gets their news
from Facebook.
-"Mom."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES)
You know,
among the worst things
that social media ever did
was it made everyone feel
they had to weigh in
on every controversial issue
or breaking news story, and...
(CHUCKLES) ...that's my job.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
In the olden days,
people would watch
the evening news and then,
well, nothing.
-They went on--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
They went on with their lives.
But today,
everybody's got to share
their theory on everything.
Whether it's trans women
on the swim team
or whether dwarfs
should play non-dwarfs
in the Snow White movie.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(SIGHS)
But has anyone noticed
that the more time
everyone spends telling
everyone else
their political position
on everything,
the more we've been
at each other's throats.
Here's a trend I would love
to see on Twitter.
"No opinion."
-(DONNA BRAZILE LAUGHING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Where people take issues
like the debt limit
and climate science
and post,
"I don't know shit about this."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(DONNA CHUCKLING)
Thursday is Thanksgiving,
the cherished yearly celebration
when distant friends
and scattered family members
gather together
-to fight about Donald Trump...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...the other butterball.
-(DONNA LAUGHING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(DONNA SIGHING)
-(LAUGHS)
But not just Trump,
we'll also argue about abortion
and critical race theory
and guns and prisons
and schools, and this year,
we're fighting about Israel.
But here's the thing,
you're not actually
legally obliged
to have an opinion.
Do you know why the Indians
and the pilgrims
were able to sit peaceably
through the first Thanksgiving?
Because nobody
brought up politics.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
That's true.
Even though I'm sure the Indians
had strong feelings
about immigration.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-True.
Back in the '90s,
Michael Jordan famously said
he stayed out of politics
because quote,
"Republicans buy sneakers too."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And then Kanye said,
"And don't forget Nazis."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES)
But the days
when someone could say that
and keep their opinions
to themselves,
those days are gone.
Big Brother says
that having no opinion
is not an option anymore.
You must participate
in this online circle jerk
-or you'll be--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Or you will be seen
as an insensitive prick
who's single-handedly
obstructing much-needed progress
in the world.
-Did you post a black square?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
No? Well, that's why
there's still racism.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(SIGHS)
(LAUGHS)
You see, here's what it is,
the younger generations
were raised wrong.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So they can't stand,
for a minute,
the idea that other people
have opinions different
than their own.
Fifty-nine percent
of consumers now
will buy a product,
or boycott a product,
based solely
on the political stance
a company takes.
Huh? Gen Z consumers need
to know
if their spermicide
condemns cockfighting.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Disney didn't wanna get
into a big pissing match
with Ron DeSantis
about sex in grade school.
But its employees sure did,
so they had to.
Now, one side thinks Disney
said too much,
the other thinks
it didn't say enough.
We see this pattern
over and over.
We saw it with Bud Light,
when they did ads
with a trans influencer,
and MAGA nation thought
it was a plot
to use beer to turn them gay.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
Pride Month is now a minefield
for corporations.
This year, Target put up
special rainbow displays
which presented Christians
who oppose gay marriage
with an impossible choice,
either support a gay lifestyle
and go to hell for it
or shop at Kohl's.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(SIGHS)
And why did I ever need to know
that Chick-fil-A
is chicken that's "Christian"?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Can't it just be chicken?
This is unsustainable.
It's unsustainable.
To politicize everything
means we're always fighting
because we don't all agree
and never will,
and most people don't want
to be forced to say anything.
Kylie Jenner posted,
"We stand
with the people of Israel."
And then deleted it,
which is pretty much
the opposite of standing with.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
One executive
who was interviewed
about the pressure
companies have felt
to make a statement
about the Hamas war said...
(READS PROMPT)
Exactly.
And I bet you still don't,
so why not
just shut the fuck up.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-I don't need-- (CHUCKLES)
I don't need to be reminded
that Spanx's stretchy pants
-are against racism.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I don't care
who Frito Lay stands with.
You make bean dip, just do that.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Stop making everything
about some other
random deeper shit.
When I hear,
"Astroglide want you to know
that they support--" Stop.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-You lost me.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-I don't want-- (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
I don't want to--
I don't wanna live
in this annoying world
where "they"
can't drink Bud Light
and we can't eat Chick-fil-A.
I'm sick of all of it.
This Thanksgiving,
I'm gonna make beer can chicken
-with Bud Light and Chick-fil-A.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
And anybody who doesn't like it
can go fuck themselves.
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody!